vous avez des problèmes avec internet à
la maison internet ne passe pas partout
vous avez des zones dont vous êtes par
exemple dans votre chambre et ça ne
marche plus le réseau diminue c'est
parce que votre wifi ne passe pas
facilement
soit les murs le plafond vous êtes des
murs trop épais ou alors vous êtes
peut-être juste trop évoluer votre
routeur alors rassurez vous ce n'est pas
une fatalité on peut réussir à
solutionner tout ça et j'ai un produit
très sympa avons présenté qui permettra
de solutionner ce problème facilement et
ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
[Musique]
regardez c'est ça c'est ici il est beau
c'est lui c'est le dévot l'eau mèche
wifi 2000 toujours d'une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec des vélos
pour vous présenter cette solution qui
vous permettra de solutionner vos
problèmes de wifi à la maison vous allez
pouvoir avoir du wifi partout si vous
avez une très grande maison vous avez un
château vous avez des maisons avec
quatre étages vous avez des murs très
épais des murs en pierre hivernât stocks
et bien un terrible à pouvoir circuler
partout facilement et ça c'est une très
très bonne nouvelle
et vous allez pouvoir dire stop wifi
problèmes comme ça au moins les choses
sont claires alors je vous montre
comment ça marche ça c'est votre maison
c'était pas vraiment votre maison en
tout cas c'est une maison ça pourrait
ressembler la vôtre ici vous avez votre
box et le réseau passe très bien dans
cette partie là on va dire ce qu'ils
vous ont mis en vert clair qui fait que
vous avez des hommes nombre ici sur le
côté il votre maison au bout de la
cuisine par exemple dans le jardin ne
parlons même pas en haut à l'étagé là
vous galérez fut carrément deuxième
étage et si vous n'avez absolument rien
et là franchement c'est la grosse galère
je vous présente aujourd'hui c'est le
multiroom quitte c'est à dire que vous
en avez 3 à l'intérieur ce sont des cpl
expliquer comment ça marche quelques
instants on à détroit pour une très
bonne répartition du réseau dans votre
maison vous voulez acheter également
s'il appelle le starter kit avec
uniquement deux qui après vous pouvez
rajouter des extensions vous achetez une
par une
si vous avez des très grandes maisons
déjà avec ça peut courir 180 m² avec le
starter qui faisait à 120 mètres carrés
si vous avez 300 400 mètres carrés bien
vous comprenez vous rajoutez des
boîtiers cpl est comme ça vous allez
tout couvrir très facilement tout ça
avec un seul essai civil alors je
n'explique comment ça marche ca ca
technologies qu'on va appeler cpr vous
avez un premier boîtier vous avez
branché à proximité de votre routeur
dans votre prise électrique
votre compteur c'est votre box votre box
internet quelles qu'elles soient toutes
marques ça marche avec toutes les
marques tous les fournisseurs d'accès
sans aucun problème
vous sortez un petit câble ethernet qui
est fournie ici depuis votre box et vous
le branchez dans notre cpl ça permettra
d'emmener le signal internet directement
dans votre cpu qu'est-ce que bat à votre
cpl et bien il va transformer le signal
internet en signal électrique
vous aviez à brancher le cpl où vous le
souhaitez par exemple ici au milieu à
l'étagé puis le dernier tout temps aux
extrémités ici l étage qui vous
permettra d'avoir une couverture
homogène partout dans votre maison et ça
c'est génial que ce soit à l'intérieur
mais en plus ici à l'extérieur dans le
jardin si vous voulez mettre une petite
enceinte connectez vous pourrez et ça
c'est très très chouette et votre signal
internet
il va passer dans votre circuit
électrique à l'endroit où internet ne
passe pas vous le branchez dans la prise
électrique lui va récupérer le signal
qui passent dans les fils électriques
il va le récupérer il va le transformer
et il va se substituer à votre routeur
et il va y mettre du wifi avec
exactement le même ssid alors assez
sideci sous ne vous parle pas c'est le
nom de votre wifi à la maison si par
exemple votre wifi s'appelle maison 1 et
bien s'appellera maison un endroit
s'appellera maison à un autre endroit et
ce qui est vraiment génial avec ça c'est
que c'est complètement transparente vous
vous balle dans votre maison
il a un seul réseau internet via ce ssid
il reconnaît partout le réseau maison 1
que vous soyez au rez de chaussée et au
premier étage au deuxième étage
vous n'avez pas besoin vous de changer
de le déconnecter 6 à nos îles value
automatiquement se connecter au réseau
le plus proche sur le cpl auquel il a
capté le meilleur réseau donc pour vous
c'est transparent c'est bien ça permet
d'emmener internet partout dans votre
maison là je vous parle d'état parce que
souvent c'est les étages qui pose
problème mais si vous avez des murs très
épais un appartement qui est très long
eh bien vous le mettez d'un bout à
l'autre
ça fera exactement la même chose et ça
marchera pas parfaitement bien aux cas
de figure vous avez votre box qui est je
sais pas un bras dans un rangement local
technique et vous avez votre décodeur
télé qui est beaucoup plus loin sauf que
chez vous et bien vous n'avez pas de
prise ethernet pour emmener le signal
d'un point a au point b bien on fait
exactement la même chose avec votre cps
à caen pour les mettre votre télé dans
votre salon mais vous n'avez pas la boxe
à côté ou alors pourquoi pas cette télé
dans votre chambre
et bien ce que vous faites vous
n'utilisez la prise ethernet de votre
cpl vous le brancher directement dans
votre décodeur décodeur qui fonctionne
bien évidemment avec la box de votre
opérateur vous allez pouvoir déporter
votre décodeur partout très facilement
sans aucun problème et ça aussi c'est un
des usages qui est extrêmement
intéressant et par exemple
même manière si vous avez un pc gaming
vous jouez pas dans un bureau et vous
voulez vraiment optimisé une paille sur
le motif que vous voulez vraiment le
meilleur le meilleur le meilleur de la
collection grâce à une connexion
internet
eh bien vous branchez votre pc
directement sur la prise ethernet de
votre cpl comme ça vous allez avoir
invité à ce qui est vraiment optimisé
qui ira plus vite que celle du wifi et
ça aussi c'est vachement bien
à l'intérieur vous avez bien évidemment
un petit guide qui vous explique comment
ça marche comment l'installer très très
facilement ça c'est cool les voyants
étaient employés nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de voir réellement à
quoi ça va ressembler le cpl c'est ça ça
c'est réellement ce qui nous intéresse
nous avons branché c'est parti là dans
votre prise électrique et sur le dessus
ou des pouvoirs dire utilisez votre
prise normalement classiquement c'est
une prise électrique tout ce qui est
plus simple ça vous évite devenir
condamné une prise électrique devons
pouvoir l'utiliser pour brancher un
aspirateur ce que vous voulez votre
ordinateur
ça c'est à vous de voir vous récupérez
deux prises ethernet pour venir brancher
un ordinateur de gaming si vous le
souhaitez et branché un décodeur tout ce
que vous voulez directement ici ça s'est
très très bien vendu ce petit boîtier
vous le branchez vous le posez chez vous
il va émettre du wifi en récupérant via
le signal électrique et vous en avez un
vous avez bien évidemment un deuxième
qui est planqué là vous en avez un
troisième qui est planqué là et vous
avez un câble ethernet pour venir vous
brancher à votre box vous le branchez
d'un côté dans le cpl up paf traque très
facilement et vous branchez de l'autre
côté sur votre box pour récupérer le
signal directement et venir l'injecter
dans votre circuit électrique grâce aux
dévôts lommel wifi 2 de pouvoir créer un
réseau maillé chez vous avec des cps
vous avoir positionné dans tous les
endroits stratégiques avec une
couverture wifi au gold gen dans votre
intérieur et vous pouvez connecter
jusqu'à 100 appareils sur deux canaux de
fréquence vous pouvez venir les piloter
les paramétrer depuis une application
sur iphone os android mais également
depuis votre navigateur
que vous soyez sur windows sur mac ou
sur linux
voilà le fonctionnement dans
l'application je suis branché ici sur ma
livebox vous dis n'importe quelle box
sera très très bien la faire il va
reconnaître ici mais deux cpl que j'ai
branché
bon j'en ai branché deux jeux pour
empocher 3 et si j'en ai branché que
deux vous n'étiez dans le menu vous avez
votre vue d'ensemble réseau c'est
celle-là telle que vous la voyez pour
venir a ajouté un nouveau produit des
mises à jour si besoin pourrait venir
renommée vos appareils vous avez les
paramètres wifi le support on voit
quelques infos puis j'ai des paramètres
si je souhaite aller sur un mode avancé
en réalité vous n'êtes pas vraiment beau
devenir dans votre application si ce
n'est pour le paramétrer au départ tout
est très simple très transparent une
fois qu'ils sont branchés vous avez le
même et ses six départs tout c'est très
pratique très cimpor et ça va vraiment
ça marche très très bien et ils vous
permettront d'avoir internet jusqu'à 2
gigas alors il faut déjà que vous ayez
de l'internet 2 gigas en sortie de boxe
pour que ça marche si vous n'avez pas le
talent est de rigueur quand il boxe ça
ne va pas vous créer du de giga mais si
vous avez de la fibre ultra puissante et
bienvenue en tout cas ils peuvent aller
jusqu'à 2 gigas et vous permettra bien
évidemment d'avoir internet partout ça
c'est la très très bonne nouvelle mais
par exemple si vous êtes le soir cocher
dans votre sang et là vous ne captez pas
internet
et bien vous allez pouvoir regarder vos
séries vos films en streaming par
exemple sans problème pour le gaming je
vous le dis en branchant votre
ordinateur directement sur l'internet
des pouvoir aller très vite pour écouter
de la musique bien évidemment sur des
enceintes connectés là où avant vous ne
pouviez pas le faire et bien évidemment
on pensera au télétravail parce que oui
en ce moment tout le monde télétravail
donc si vous êtes 2 à télétravailler et
bien il peut y en avoir un qui est dans
un bureau lot qui est dans sa loge je ne
sais pas je ne connais pas votre façon
je ne connais pas la configuration mais
pour les grands espaces et bien vous
allez pouvoir emmener internet partout
pour solutionner le calme à la maison
éviter que tout le monde dans le même
endroit et que tout le monde se marchent
dessus
si vous avez des appels téléphoniques
professionnel vous faites de la vision
et vous aider dans la même pièce et
moment ça peut rapidement être compliqué
grâce aux dévôts lomé chrif id2 vous
allez pouvoir connecter bien évidemment
vos ordinateurs ordinateur bureau
ordinateur portable un smartphone une
tablette
une smart tv une console enfin tout ce
qui se connecte en wifi est compatible
avec ces petites bêtes là
la fabrication est allemande et vous
avez une garantie 3 ans autant vous dire
qu'ici c'est 10 arrivent ces produits
vous intéresse je vous ai mis un lien en
bas d'un description vous invite à venir
le découvrir plus de rock plus d'infos
sur le site de développer ça c'est
vachement bien et question tarif
toujours une question de prix le starter
kit coûte 249 euros 90 et le multi
rootkit 369 euros 90 nous allons pouvoir
venir créer ici votre réseau maillé en
fonction de vos besoins et vous besoin
réellement d'un multi room petit avec 3
cpl pas nécessairement peut-être que
deux vous suffiront un qui va vers votre
box et l'autre vous allez déporté dans
une zone d'ombré
ici vous avez plusieurs zones d'ombré
bien de pouvoir mettre plein de cpl pour
avoir internet d'une façon homogène chez
vous et ça c'est vraiment une excellente
nouvelle vous invite donc à cliquer sur
le lien en bas dans la description pour
découvrir des vau-l'eau
méchoui filles 2 va venir solutionner
tous vos problèmes d'internet à la
maison à vos crayons son réseau maillé
wifi et syfy plus une très très bonne
nouvelle à vous de me dire vous ce que
vous en pensez on va aux commentaires
est-ce que vous avez des problèmes de
connexion internet à la maison et est-ce
que vous avez des zones d'ombré est ce
que ces zones d'ombré sont allés tâches
ou alors dans d'autres pièces où
quelqu'un vous êtes un appartement très
grand ou alors des murs très épais des
mois donc tout ça en bas en commentaire
quant à nous on se retrouve très vite
pour continuer à parler siècle ou
j'embrasse vous remercie des gros bisous
et à très vite pour le soin de vous kawa